yo it's the bullet cap podcast man
listen we got a special guest in here uh
someone who i've looked up to for a very
long time a legend in the game
peter rosenberg ladies and gentlemen
what's up everybody
makes me feel both good and old yeah i
mean you know it's crazy because i
remember
uh i was like super early on um
on wanap this is way before you guys got
the morning show
and uh i think you guys had
i forget what forum you had like where
listeners could hit you all up i don't
remember if i hit you up on like
instant messenger or oh really you
reached out
yeah dude i remember the the one of the
episodes i remember like way back was
like
around the time sean taylor died you
guys talking about that like
yeah man i was i was uh you know like
like when you guys
i i missed the days when and then i'm
glad that these days have kind of come
back with juanep
before it was really about interviews
when it was just you guys just shooting
the [ __ ] about your favorite fast food
places across the country
[Laughter]
but but yeah but like you know uh yeah
man you're a legend bro so
you know it's it's good to see you and
um you uh
you got a new album coming out which i
feel like is way overdue
i know it's like it's funny for the
people who like don't really understand
how the music
business works they're like you know
like on my sports side of things it's
like you're putting out an album
what and then for the people in the
business who get it like about time you
put out a damn album man what are you
doing
yeah i feel like this is something that
i first of all i can only imagine
how uh annoying and tedious it is to
deal with
different teams of management and
artists and you know
it's it's it's it's i know it's a
process it had to have been a process
when did you kind of
originally start putting everything
together where you were like okay
this is an album situation um
it was because it had been it had come
through like different ideas and
and moments and iterations this final
iteration of what it turned out to be
it was really like end of the summer
that i started thinking about it and in
an early fall that i started
sort of digging into it but now that you
mention that
yo i don't i didn't deal with any teams
on this whole thing
oh that's everyone everyone on this
project is indy
i don't have any there's no label
clearing
right like it's a it's a great first
album for me
because i should i continue to go
forward and do more i'm sure you're
right i'll have to deal with more
[ __ ] right and in this case it was
like
you might deal with someone's right hand
man right right right right
but you're not you're not i'm not
dealing with labels like things were
just
they were just done i haven't even
finished having all the business
conversations yet like i got to set up
everyone's splits and do all the work
everyone's just like yeah here's a verse
let's go yeah hey and
well you know for people to realize like
it's a homage to your the show you that
that you came to hot97 to originally do
real late yeah that's that's the whole
album theme was just uh
i was i was stressing about what to call
it i had like half of it done
and i reached out to my boy disco
vietnam who produced three songs on the
project he did the flea lord rock marcy
he did the ghostface
crimeapple jim jones and he did the the
second generation woo
and i would i'd send him a text and i'm
like ah i really want a name because
it's hard for me to like get in the the
the frame of mind to finishing this
whole thing and taking next steps
when i don't know what the project is
called
right and in like 30 seconds he was just
like why don't you call it real late i
mean
that's kind of the show you've been
doing this whole time which kind of is
the
isn't that what this whole album really
is right and then i was like
oh [ __ ] and then i realized i'm like oh
and for the people who most people who
will hear this album don't even know
what that radio show is
it will have a totally different meaning
for them like
and then they'll see the album cover and
they'll see late night and they'll maybe
start putting together images but
for them it's not based on radio but for
the people who have it
it has a different meaning run through
uh all the
like give me all the all the features
like who all you got on the album and
you dropped three singles uh you know
you you've gotten some crazy verses so
far but who always on the album
um the intro is velvet wonder la's own
um the it's produced by dj skis
the next joint styles p ransom and dizza
okay yeah they came through
super hard um west side gun
stain of course marcus smart lee lord
and stove god cooks
hallways this is like a fun challenge
for myself by the way hallways
with uh flea lord and rock marcy
mind over matter which is i'm probably
the most pleasantly surprised with how
many people i've given the record to
mention this song because
most of the people have told me they
don't even know the artists are but they
love the song
that's uh jane nice and edo mind over
matter
um next chamber method man rayquan
willie the kid
mayhem loren has an interlude on there
um midnight sunday rasheed chappelle
produced by buck wild
by the way buck did the mayhem interlude
as well nice
um
oh the ghost face uh snake eyes
ghostface crimeapple
and and and jim jones which is [ __ ]
bananas in my opinion
goes for that ghost will have you ghost
might have my ghost might have you in
the street you might go
want to do something you shouldn't do
when you hear ghost face it's my
favorite type of ghost face
no it's it's it's reach your money in
the reach your hands on the register and
take out all the [ __ ] money ghostface
it's it's
it's [ __ ] hard um
woo generation by second generation woo
um
i want it all fly anakin and nicholas f
um and i haven't heard that i haven't
heard nicholas f in a while
i haven't heard that name in a minute
yeah he's nicholas f
is actually can you have a record with
drake
yeah he wrote no no you're not tripping
he wrote that record
he wrote the record with drake and wayne
um he might he's on a record i believe
also
yeah i think they have a record together
that was like on like the blogs back in
the day
yeah but he also wrote a drake record
back at that time too
um and yeah dear homeboy sandman which
is um that's your guy
you know and he's a he's an alien yeah
yo he's an alien he really if you listen
to that verse
he like takes you on a story it's like
it's like going inside someone's brain
and just listening to them
think on a record like he's it's he's
awesome
um you know we always get these albums
uh
that that are compilations right and and
you know i think khaled is someone who's
done a good a good job of putting albums
together and then also at times maybe
maybe not
so good of a job you know i mean
obviously it's
everything's subjective but how hard is
it to do something
like this and make it cohesive
um in this case
it was very easy
because i picked artists who made sense
right so you you're not
trying to get one artist to agree to
make the record
and then another artist on a different
song who's gonna
not gonna pick anything similar to what
this other artist was feeling right
right
right so as a result so really like
i was able to sort of use my ear
and have that work for for all the
artists that were selected
if i had tried to get too crazy
ultimately i would have had like this
this this
disconnect the the least connected
record
is probably the homeboy sandman record
which is why i put it last
um that's just stylistically it's just
he's
he's in his own back all together 100
it's not like i don't think you hear it
you go why is this here
but i think it's different enough you
know my man quartermaine
was listening to a rough of the album
and he was like i don't know if this
fits
and while i disagreed on some level and
i wanted on the album i i took his
advice that it didn't fit in the middle
of the project
and i ended up moving it along and now i
like where it is but to me kev it's like
hopefully you know what ends up coming
across
in this project is there are people out
there like yo i can't [ __ ] stand
rosenberg that guy sucks [ __ ] him
culture vulture piece of [ __ ]
but you know what he put a nice album
together
he's got a good ear this [ __ ] is
cohesive
like because that's that's honestly
that's my biggest source of pride in it
is that i just think it's like this does
not sound like a soundtrack where
you're like why is that song there i
think it you would believe these artists
were in some level of communication or
right right
right well that's that's i think that's
the hardest part about doing a project
like this
is like usually these types of projects
we love songs off of them but to like
just press play and ride out like you
know there's there's like
back in the day there was like the sound
bombings and there was there there has
been great examples of that but
i feel like lately we haven't really had
a a shining example especially when it
comes to
um you know the boom bap [ __ ] i kind of
look at every static select album is a
cohesive piece
you know but he's the producer on them
and he doesn't he's probably
the best at putting albums together that
flow
and you know again static is an artist
he actually is making the music but as
far as
which is both more impressive and also
so a he's much more talented than me of
course but also
he's got an easier task in terms of
forming it because it's his music yeah
he's making the beat so he knows yeah
exactly yeah
um you mentioned i was you mentioned
the culture vulture thing do you did you
see the meme that they posted on twitter
and it was me
and you and uh adam22 and vlad
uh someone posted like a meme of all
four of our photos and they said this is
hip-hop media
yeah yo yo that was [ __ ] hilarious
they used like the worst photo of me
ever it was i was like oh
god that's even worse not only was not
only where
was it the idea of the photo but then a
bad picture on top of it
my main issue that i took with that was
just like
i know there are people who don't like
me i know i've said things that
people hold on to and rather than
of something that you may have done that
they liked or uh ten times when that you
did something they may have liked they
remember that
thing that made them uh not like you
but like it was just such a lazy
assessment you know
like that was just of course listen
i'll take you and i being thrown in a
category together because they're
actually legitimate similarities you
could point to
right right right right right and i
don't know what their relationships are
so i don't want to put you in a bad spot
but where you get to comparing us to
adam 22 and vlad
and i get adam 22 and vlad going
together because
they get people to say some
semi-incriminating
crazy [ __ ] like i get the whole op thing
but
you and i like two kind of dj nerds
right right right
respectful of the music and culture i
just don't that was such to me uh
that was a lazy but very funny it was
funny i just loved why like everyone
like was like defending
i feel like everyone was defending you
and me on twitter it was so funny
i was like we got something we got some
defense for sherlock
not these guys by them yeah yeah it was
pretty funny it was pretty funny man
how's uh you know it's crazy because for
people who don't know man you
legitimately do two full radio shows
every day
which is extremely impressive and it
also has to be very taxing
for your bandwidth like how how
how hard is that man because i know just
doing a four-hour morning show alone's
gotta you know at the end of it you know
for people think that we just sit in
front of a mic but it is you know we
we have to be mentally in the game you
know what i mean and you got to do that
twice a day
how do you deal with that man
um well it is tiring and the bandwidth
thing is
hard um and by the end of it you can
feel very
finished um but
i don't know i i try to go to bed
relatively early i i try to be mostly
healthy
right you know i'm not a big drugs or
alcohol guy
but although definitely during cove it
definitely affected my alcohol on the
weekend definitely picked up
of course but you know i'm very stoned
sober during the week i try to eat my
salads all week long i try to catch naps
when i can
you know i have ups and downs when it
comes to the gym
but you know and listen i also it's one
of the times like
i i'm i'm i'm only able to do both shows
because i'm not the first mike on either
show
true so i can sit back
at times and it's also a good way
to learn when to shut up you know
because
that was a big part of radio that i
didn't understand for
a really long time um
i sit back now way more than i used to
so like
you might hear a segment on with ibra
and laura in the morning
where i don't say that much right right
no i
sort of learned to have the spots like
they don't need my voice here
it's not gonna what am i adding so like
you know ebro and laura are talking
about something that that they're both
making an
impact on it it's it's really effective
am i going to add to this or in this
moment if i am
if i add is it at best not going to add
that much
right we're at work it's gonna be like
shut up white boy we didn't even need
your take on this
that's fair so there and there's
obviously their conversations
that is true too and you know i already
had the time when i was like everyone
needs to hear my voice
yes you're a very opinionated guy man
i'm an opinionated guy and i am the
first person to try to teach white
people
sometimes guess what shut up people
don't need to hear your voice
it's not every day right sometimes i
really want to i'm like no
i can contribute this is somewhat useful
trust me you know like we have certain
conversations i'm like well
you know when we had our covid
conversations and vaccine conversations
i was quick to weigh in
like listen i'm here to tell people the
world
if this is a plot to hurt black people
which is a
reasonable thought to have right if that
is true i just want you to know
all the white people i know are taking
it
right we're all we're all in it together
yeah on this one
so there my voice was valuable i can
tell you my experience but in some
situations you know and sometimes as an
ally my voice is useful sometimes it's
not
you know and then on the k show yo
sometimes we get into subjects and i'm
like i just don't have a ton to
contribute here and i don't want to be
the person who's talking to me have my
my voice heard
i already have a lot of time to talk
right right you know and then sometimes
they tell me oh we need to hear from you
more you know like hey
we know you're not that into baseball
but some of our audience
you're the reason they're here and if
you don't talk about baseball they're
really not going to give a [ __ ]
right so finding that balance can be can
be hard but
[ __ ] sometimes you just need to sit back
and rest and just well and then you're
also you also had a
a brief stint as as the 24 7 champion
you know what i mean i mean i mean you
call it bri
you know brief classic media i hate you
know
just tearing me down yo you are like dj
vlad thank you thank you thank you thank
you
i'll take it shout out to vlad no but
it's crazy because
you know i know how how big of a fan you
are of wrestling and how
inter i mean i give you credit over
everyone uh over any rapper over
everyone as far as bringing wrestling
into the hip-hop space
is the real deal this is the real deal
gun is the real deal conway a hundred
percent people i don't want
a lot of people love hip-hop but no you
were first i may have not been
but i was definitely the first yeah um
and
winning that title was it's gotta be
that's gotta be like that might be i can
only imagine out of everything you've
done in your career that has to be like
top two or three things like the fact
you held a title
in the wwe that is insane
to say out loud i know i no
and it's silly it's it's like that that
for people who don't know like that
title the 24 7 title
it's sort of a comedic it's funny yeah
like gronk
gronk had it um however yeah like robert
ronkowski had it they've had you know
silly other broadcasters
get it for two seconds but like
it does have a lineage though it is
documented like it is written
down people know who's had it and and
the craziest part about that
was that i thought it was going to maybe
be a thing i'd get an opportunity
at the pay-per-view beforehand and then
things were crazy and they're
not going to happen and i was like okay
cool and i'm like i don't think that's
ever going to happen to be honest with
you so whatever
and then i get to the royal rumble
kickoff show and we're talking and
they're
like hey so we're not going to have time
to um get it on the kickoff show
in my mind i'm kind of relieved because
i'm like i don't really know how i'm
going to do this
so i was like okay cool cool cool but i
think it's going to happen
during the main show and i was like
during the royal rumble pay-per-view
right this is the point of view that
even if you're like a lapsed fan
like you watch it you tune in because
yeah because you like to watch the world
rumble
yeah like if you're even like you you
used to be a wrestling fan or like
now you're all indie but you you like to
hate on wwe
everyone watches the rumble if you have
any ounce of love for wrestling in your
blood
yeah so i was like oh okay
and i really came to have a new
appreciation i thought
i thought being as big a fan as i am and
i know you're a big
fan like that i already had
all the respect and appreciation that
one could possibly have for these people
right
and in having to do this basic
thing yeah the amount of thought
and practice right
like i spent that day practicing by the
way i still [ __ ] it up right right
right though it looked enough i did the
job but like
i did not the way i was exactly supposed
to on either account and any of the
things i did
and to think about that they do it live
all the time like
you have one shot yeah you got excited
yeah if you [ __ ] it up once it's
that's the that's your only time you get
yeah
and and by the way our truth made it
very clear to me
he was like if you botch the pin i'm
kicking out
wow i've never actually said that i
don't think before there you go i'll
give you guys listen
if i was like if you botch this i'm
kicking out you ain't getting the belt
you're not getting it you're just good
and i was like all right i was like well
listen i still tried
right right right i don't want to
disrespect the craft if i can't pull it
off
that's what you should do right attitude
is so strong
our truth could have done anything he
wanted
of course it could have kicked out fly
back to the desk
i mean like he is he's an athlete
you know how old are truth i assume he's
old as [ __ ] because he has been around
forever forever but he just he just
looks great
he's got to be 50. he's like 50 years
old oh yeah
he's got to be 50. he's got to be 50.
yeah when he raps
when he raps he sounds like he's 50. so
i would assume 50.
you're an [ __ ] he looks dirty but
when he raps you're like oh he's very
yeah he's 50 for sure
um yo so you know the one thing
i wanted i wanted to get your take on
something that's obviously extremely uh
controversial and polarizing at the
moment because i've spoken with
people from both sides and i wanted to
kind of you know get your
understanding of uh what's going on
you know in israel and palestine because
you know i i've talked to artists like
belly and
you know certain people who are
extremely passionate uh you know on the
palestinian side and i've talked to some
of my jewish friends and
you know i always stay away from
subjects that i don't fully understand
um
and i i think i might have saw you weigh
in on what andrew yang said
maybe i'm wrong on that i did i did yeah
so
um you know for people who don't know
you're jewish um what what are your
i guess kind of what's your consensus or
your thoughts about
about everything that's going on man
so this is an incredibly
uh complicated subject and i'm not i'm
not saying that just like in a light
generic way um you know it's a subject
that sort of like
you know dominated the conversation in
my house my whole life
um you know and like i
i went to israel for the first time when
i was four years old right
uh israel's super important uh to my
family
and to all jews um however
uh you know decency
and and and empathy and critical
thinking
can allow us to uh have a lot of love
for a place
and still be critical um i am not going
to oversimplify the entire thing because
the truth is
palestinians have been um marginalized
um they've been in many situations just
treated like garbage like just not
treated in
a humane way um and it's it's sickening
and upsetting
um and simultaneously
you know israel israel's existence is
important to the jewish people and
there's some people who don't agree with
that
inherently they do not believe israel
should should exist that that is a real
faction of people that exists
unfortunately hamas is in that category
right
right so you have these people who have
been
caught in a terrible position the
palestinian people
and we had opportunities at peace in the
past
with robin and arafat which were
destroyed
and you know now you have uh
a really complex circumstance but the
bottom line is this
i hold the israeli government to a high
standard because that's
number one because of the the the money
the power the organization
the us backpacking and also because i'm
jewish and
and i believe in a jewish state so i
hold
in my sense my people right if you will
to a standard
i i'm not some person who believes you
just
wave the flag of your country blindly or
whoever
willy-nilly like it's i know this sounds
silly and crude
but i always go back to sports and i
know you're a sports fan so
i love the washington football team so
much
i hate the owner i publicly tell
everyone i hate the owner
i want him to sell the team i don't want
it to have anything to do with the team
i first suggested and and demanded the
name be changed like
13 years ago or something on camera that
was the first time publicly
right i still love the team i still
rooted for the team while
literally not wanting them to even have
their name
sort of look at the way we we deal with
our countries of origin the same way
just because you love israel and see its
existence as important
does not mean you have to believe in
everything
they do and and also
just because you're a palestinian does
not mean
that you do or should ride with hamas
right so it's an it's a it's a really
bad situation
i think that netanyahu has been
generally terrible
and i've some of my jewish friends have
compared him
to like if trump won over there like
he's extremely right-wing
extremely he's only got more right wing
over the years right because that
became a winning thing because we're
seeing this whole like
real real white nationalism all across
the world
and he he's written with going further
right as the years have gone on
so you know how could
if i if i felt the way i felt about
trump which was that he was an
absolute nightmare in the worst and
guess what you can still love america by
the way and still feel that way
yes exactly right and now i understand
it's complicated for jews though right
because when we start hearing
israel get criticized the history of the
jewish people isn't the same history as
the course of america
a hundred percent yeah america is like
america's like the white people of
countries
right it's gonna be all right yeah i
think that the the thing that's
that's that's hard is like obviously i
what i've noticed is anyone who has
spoke out against
the actions of the israeli government it
seems as if they get
labeled right away as being an
anti-semitic person
well the thing is you have to look at
each individual person
separately that's fair but i mean i've
seen i've seen like i think dua lipa
they're trying to call her
you know people have just made
statements that saying you know
essentially hey what's going on is wrong
it seems like there's there's like uh a
narrative that goes right away
on twitter or you know that these people
are quote unquote anti-semitic and i
think that everyone can be
you know critical of of of you know like
you said
you could be critical of a country or
government's actions and still
be with the jewish people you know what
i mean and you know so i just think that
i just think it's important
i just think it's important to people to
say that like because let me explain let
me explain the other side even though
i a lot of jews hate me because i'm so
i care deeply about the well-being of
palestinians and
oh and by the way i have someone who i
know in the music industry i thought you
off the camera i said yeah i was like i
don't think
i think rosenberg says some of the
andrew gang they were like rosenberg is
a self-hating jew
and i was like jesus christ like
that's not true but all right i'll tell
you you might know the person i'll tell
you who it is later but
not on camera so exactly
i get self-hating to do because i care
about the well-being of palestinians but
on the flip side of that coin
because this is what this is what being
a measured thoughtful person
involved right um as a jew
when you see a lot of people just
putting up free palestine and
and even though you agree with that
sentiment
if you know the person who posted that
doesn't know [ __ ] about the subject
it is uncomfortable so it's hard to
explain and then and then if you add
even more to that
that you've also seen that person say
something else that seems a little wired
you might start to be like well do you
really care about palestine and do you
hate jews because that's not gonna twist
it people hate jews out here
yeah so anti-semitism is real we're
seeing in the street we see it in real
life so
it's a very uncomfortable thing to be
honest especially being someone
who thinks the israeli government is
wrong who wants
there to be a peaceful solution and i
have jews who come after me and say i'm
a self-hater
and then i have people on the other side
who say i'm a zionist monster who
doesn't
and the truth is i deeply care about
both that's how i was raised right
you know that that that is what my my
family evolved
my dad used to be militant pro-israel
militant
right at a time when it seems to be such
right
right right but things have evolved
right and now the state of israel is in
a different place so
you know it's super uncomfortable but if
you can't be someone who's able to
acknowledge
that the israeli government is [ __ ] up
and that hamas is [ __ ] up if you're
not able to acknowledge those things as
possible
i don't think we can have a reasonable
conversation that's fair man well yeah i
just wanted to get your take cause like
i said i know you're a very measured
dude
and uh you know i think that it's
important that
like you said i think the way you just
explained it is how everyone should
that's why i haven't rushed to say
anything on because i'm like look you
know what i
i don't fully understand the entire
history of what's going on so
you know but not enough people are
willing to admit that they just want to
jump in on the conversation and i get it
you want to stand next to
you know a people that's in really bad
shape and being maligned i understand
that but you should do
the research also and you should
understand why jews care about israel in
the first place
right so even if the government's [ __ ]
up and wrong
you do you should understand
why you feel it's so important to have
israel in
existence you know and by the way just
to say the people that the self-hate
thing it's like yo
my name is rosenberg and i am a public
personality who is
always openly talked about being jewish
always always proudly
always hey the whole entire tagline of
the morning show was a puerto rican in a
jew walking to a radio station
exactly it's always labelled
anybody who would ever fix their lips to
say i'm self-hating like it's so absurd
when i'm a public front-facing front
lines out there i get called
i i have dealt with anti-semitism
regularly since the internet has even
been a thing
yeah that's crazy like so it's just it's
so frustrating when you hear that
because it's like
so my opinion is different on israel
and and by the way have you even been to
israel right right
my dax my dad had these takes on israel
and these thoughts and like
he's arguing with people who israel's so
important to them but they've never been
never been
my dad's been like 40 50 times geez like
that's really where he spent time and he
has to argue with people who love israel
in theory
and he's like no i love the actual place
like i love
the place listen we got about four
minutes left before you got to hop on
the air i wanted to ask you this because
i've evolved over the years when it
comes to
uh i like to call it radio gangbanging
you know what i'm saying i used to be
one of these guys who uh would uh
whatever radio station i was on it was
[ __ ] the other station [ __ ] the other
djs
it was yeah exactly and obviously hot
and power
in new york is the quintessential radio
beef always even when i feel like it's
calming down
this past week or so with the
the the funk flex is bringing up the old
but but it's
i bring it up because i'm really close
with charlemagne
i'm really close with you charlemagne's
somebody who's
done so much for my career as far as
yeah he's done a lot for me personally
um
and both of you guys are amazing people
i know both of you guys
but what like y'all just don't [ __ ] with
each other like what
i understand that like you know
did help me understand will there ever
be a conversation between you two or
or you know cause i think at the end of
the day we've definitely had
conversations
we've definitely had personal in-person
real-life conversations
i would go as far as saying we even had
a period where we were like
cordial because we ran into each other a
bunch of times
without speaking on the
greater charlemagne issues right
um and the the allegations and the
things that kwame brown's been talking
about um
although i sometimes cannot understand
how good he's been at navigating those
things
it's it's almost mind-blowing you don't
almost believe in illuminati
but removing that i actually have tried
on multiple occasions i know this sounds
crazy like
i really did reach out on multiple
occasions for causes bigger than us for
us to come together and he [ __ ] on
so at that point i i no longer wish it
will i definitely did at some point
i've went through a lot of stuff in my
life over the last couple years
i no longer spend time thinking about
him in that way
but i will tell you pre-2016 election
i reached out about us getting together
getting together for
for voting stuff because i thought it
would make a big impact to see us all
come together
and no interest you know ebro ran into
him at a colin kaepernick thing
ibra was like let's take a picture
together this is for cap's cause he
wouldn't do it
you know and then he'll turn around and
flip the story later but that's the
reality
you know um yeah i don't spend time
thinking about him in a negative way
anymore with regards to me personally
i don't i don't um i don't know him i
i think there's a lot of [ __ ] that i
disagree with right you know
fundamentally
i i was watching an episode of sam j's
new show she was talking to this black
conservative about why they're
republicans
and the two things they mentioned they
were like well i don't want a candidate
who says
um if if you're not voting for me you're
not black and i don't want a candidate
who's like
if i need to have hot sauce in my bag i
was like damn both those things came
from breakfast club interviews
both reasons that you hate the democrats
came from breakfast club interviews
what the [ __ ] are y'all doing yeah but
that's not their fault that
those things were said oh it's never
their fault
it's never going to be there you can't
put that on that way
it just ends up that way that kamala
harris ended up looking bad for the
tupac gap
and it just was coincidence that biden
got out of sorts and then he said
something dumb
and hillary clinton might in fact be
from arkansas and keep saucing her back
but i'm just saying those things all
happen
well that means that i i can't help but
cut a promo because i'm into wrestling
but you're right
the truth is i don't have any ill will i
used to be close with uh angela
we're not anymore right nothing but love
for end i don't i don't i don't wish oh
well
on anyone well that's good i really
don't well look you gotta you gotta
skate off and do a radio show sir
uh we could we could have done a few
hours but we'll wait for you when you
come to l.a we'll do it we'll do it big
yeah you know we'll have beverages we'll
do the whole thing right all right
brother sounds good man have a good day
and thank you for your time the album is
out next friday right
my guy it sure is june 4th real late
thank you kev yes sir